would you say that you were bigger on
nico nico than you were on youtube back
in the day or is that where you found
your growth
um before i started nico nico um i was
my listeners uh more more on a youtube
level but then
from nico nico uh it went like booms
yeah i think my crowd started bigger on
nico nico
because what's what's always fascinated
me is the difference between
say like the youtube anime culture and
just nico nico
in general i feel like it goes like a
different planet yeah it's to me as like
a western anime fan i see some of the
stuff that's going on in nico nico and
it just
one makes zero sense to me and two has
seems to have some of the most talented
creators i've like
ever seen and yeah definitely and
nobody's heard about them because
they're on this
on this one japanese website that no
foreigner can ever figure out it's it's
also insane with nico nico as well
because like i used to go on nico nico
quite a bit
uh like even before youtube and it's
just yeah as you said like
for some reason creators on nico nico
are just on a different level and
none of them like do it you know for
like ad revenue or anything yeah they
literally do it out of passion
yeah and like and you know like so many
like utaitas and like seeing japanese
singers are all found
uh someone who does like covers of
vocaloid and anime and stuff like that
basically it's like it's like
youtube has its own version of a titan
it's called you thai taste
oh i think i have heard of this yeah
yeah so basically it's just like a
uh you know an amateur singer who does
covers of anime
that's good and stuff like that and then
a lot of them get you know
uh major record labels like so how long
were you uploading on nico nico before
you got like
any kind of traction i am i was
completely newbie
so um there were so many bigger greater
uh days before me doing their thing
and i just started and i uploaded i
happened to upload my first videos
i think it was like 2000 really late
2010 into 2011
and then 2011 early in 2011 i got
noticed by my director so it was like a
few months oh wow
and so i have no friends on youtube
um yeah and my probably uh nico nico
wikipedia thingy bobber is really like
short and
sweet i mean because you were on a
flight not even a year
i'll be honest if someone contacted me
like four months into youtubing like
listen i want to give you a record deal
i'd be like
this sounds like a scam yeah i thought
so
yeah i thought so but i got a direct um
sort of contact through a creator oh
okay
so who is called a vocaloid p uh
producer
so um so confusing yeah i know the words
on nico nico are like really
sort of [ __ ] yeah i'm trying to i'm
trying to i mean it's like when you're
when you're going tick-tock you're like
what the [ __ ] is happening
why is everyone thinking what's going on
i haven't got that far because to me
i've always known about the vocaloid
community
but as someone who's quite ingrained
into the web culture i had
the vocaloid fad just kind of like went
and went by and i had no idea
about anything that was going on in that
community legit the only
way i could understand like half the
memes that were existent on nico nico
was to just like bite the ball and go on
two chan
i'm just like because it's all just
there so i was like [ __ ] i guess i have
to go into this cesspool to understand
it
and even then i can only understand
maybe like 30 of it before i was like
i just don't get this i don't get this
at all yeah so like what was the
difference between like say nikon
ecoculture and uploading to youtube for
you for yourself
um well like you said nico nico is very
like a closed community everyone is
understanding they're like
you know friends on there and it's like
a parallel universe it
are people nice on that platform very
nice very nice wow
that is a power location that i'm too
knowledgeable about okay so
um yeah but i just think that it's like
a universe in itself
so um they kind of move
along in the world at their own pace so
that was kind of different from youtube
youtube is very open
worldwide and there's so many people on
there
so um yeah because i feel like because
nico nico is so
focused on the kind of like the anime
and
weeb side of the community that it's it
feels much more closed off
um and especially with the japanese
speaking as well
but that that's that just makes me want
to get into it more because it seems
like an
untapped gold mine are you sure about
that i mean i don't know i don't know
because i
from from the outside looking in there
seems to be like such a gold mine of
content there
especially people getting scouted
professionally on that platform just
shows that there is
real talent in that platform honestly
like some i'd say some of the best anime
based memes have
all originated from nico
especially in asia it's big and um i
i'd have to say though um the talent on
nico nico
is amazing unmatched unmatched that's
why i think all these record labels
what katakawa and sneaker oh wow oh
really i didn't know that
well thank you shadow such a great
platform
i'm not endorsed to say that at all